- Oh, my gosh, I'm such a fan.
- Hi.
I'm gonna keep it cool.
- Aw. Same.
I'm gonna be so cool.
You're not even gonna know.
So, but you're from a small town.
I am as well, but it's
a small town in Ireland.
So like, what was it like,
like how small are we talking?
- Well, I'm, I'm really from a village.
That's outside of a town.
So the village-
- You don't even get town
- We don't get town.
- It's village.
- No
(laughing)
- Like we had a school,
we had a church, we had
- [Kelly] Just one?
- Uh huh. One post office.
And then of course, cause it's Ireland.
We had two pubs.
- [Kelly] Of course.
- Just, just to balance things out.
- One church, two pubs.
- [Caitriona] Yeah.
- I love it. I love it.
So, so how did you get into acting cause
did you always love
acting when you were a kid
were you exposed to it?
- Yeah. You know, it's
one of those things.
I think you're sort of born
with this crazy desire to
- [Kelly] That kind of innate feeling.
- Yeah. And I was one of
those annoying little kids.
You know, I was always
running around the house,
kind of doing impressions
and annoying everybody
and, you know, I think
it just was inevitable.
And when I finished
school, it was like, right.
I'm gonna go to college, which I did.
And then I sort of took a
detour for a long time, but it
I got back to it about 10 years ago.
- [Kelly] Oh I love that.
I love that.
Well, I I'm so happy you did.
I love you.
Well, so wait, you had
a son last year, right?
- Not even six months.
- Not even?
- Not even six months ago.
- Oh my gosh.
- Yeah.
- Six months.
So how early did you go back to work?
- Eight weeks.
- What?
- It was just press,
but still, yeah.
- Okay. I did three months.
I took three months and I
and I still think I
should have taken more.
- [Caitriona] It's crazy.
- It's a lot.
I mean like thank God-
- The sleep training,
the trying to get everything-
- [Caitriona] Well, sleep training.
We're just going through
now because I don't know.
I think like everybody
you, you sort of get into bad habits and-
- Oh no. What was yours?
- I mean, not putting him
down awake, this whole thing of like-
- Oh to so he can self soothe?
- Yeah. The way it was explained to me is
that you're giving a gift to them.
Right? Cause they think-
- Exactly.
- You know, as a parent
- That's why it was explained-
- You're sort of like so anxious
and you're like, oh my God they're crying.
I need to like step in.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But you're stopping them learning
a really important skill.
- And somebody told me that literally it's
like the one everybody
gives you so many books.
And so many advice is so much advice.
And it's like the one
thing that really stuck.